hiv medikament ergebnisse machen die
forscher sprachlos maß in höchster
auflösung und wir kennen unser universum
nicht das sind drei der fünf themen in
den klicks zum top 5 news jetzt geht's
los
krankenhäuser machen krank jeder mensch
hat ja an in und um seinen körper
bakterien es ganz normal die
mikroorganismen wandern ja sogar mit uns
mehr als 10.000 verschiedene bakterien
leben in und um uns menschen herum krank
werden wir nicht unbedingt wegen diesen
bakterien krank wird man einer neuen
studie des european centre for disease
prevention and control in stockholm nach
in krankenhäusern in den räumlichkeiten
von europäischen krankenhäusern kliniken
und ähnlichen erkranken jährlich rund
2,5 millionen menschen an den
sogenannten krankenhauskeimen wie zum
beispiel durchfallerreger infektionen an
der lunge und so weiter und bezogen auf
30 europäische länder sterben sogar
91.000 infizierte an den keimen und ja
ihr könnt es euch vielleicht schon
denken der grund dafür liegt zum
großteil an resistenzen die
antibiotikaresistenz zb zitat umso
wichtiger ist es sich verstärkt um die
vorbeugung und bekämpfung solcher
infektionen zu bemühen um die
europäischen krankenhäuser letztendlich
zu sicheren orten zu machen sagen die
wissenschaftler im fachmagazin plos
medicine dieser krank werden im
krankenhaus teufelskreis kostet uns
europäer in einem einzigen jahr
ganze zwei millionen potenzielle gesunde
lebensjahre maß in höchster auflösung
der rote planet beschäftigt uns in
letzter zeit ja immer wieder und auch
heute gibt es etwas spektakuläres
während die lande sondern auf dem mars
den höhepunkt der sturmsaison erwarten
hat die übermaß fliegende nasa-raumsonde
medien fotos über fotos von dem planeten
geschossen einige dieser fotos haben
jetzt für aufregung gesorgt zitat maven
hat in den letzten monaten hunderte
aufnahmen gemacht und uns damit den mars
in bisher höchster uv auflösung gezeigt
berichtet nick schneider von der
university of colorado in boulder die im
ultravioletten bereich aufgezeichneten
bilder gewähren den forschern einen
tiefen einblick in die wolken dynamik
und das ozon hier in altrosa auf dem
roten planeten anhand der neuen
aufnahmen konnten die experten frühere
aufnahmen zum so genannten nacht glühen
bestätigen erreichen sonnenstrahlen maß
stoßen sie foto chemische reaktionen an
darunter auch die spaltung von
kohlenstoffdioxid die gespaltenen
teilchen schwirren dann im verlauf des
tages über die marsoberfläche und werden
von den mars winden auf die von der
sonne abgewendete seite transportiert
dort läuft dann eine weitere reaktion ab
stickstoff und sauerstoff verschmelzen
sich zu stickstoffmonoxid letztere
reaktion zeigt sich auf den meeren
aufzeichnungen im ultraviolett wir
kennen unser universum nicht wie viele
sterne gibt es eigentlich im universum
bezieht man die frage auf unserer
heimatgalaxie die milchstraße scheint
die antwort sehr einfach zu sein
die milchstraße umfasst rund 300
milliarden sterne wobei auch das nicht
korrekt ist da ständig sterne sterben
stichwort supernovae und auch ständig
neue sterne entstehen also exakt geht
das nicht im gesamten universum sollen
es grob geschätzt also grob zehn
milliarden sterne seien diese grobe
schätzung ist einigen wissenschaftlern
verständlicherweise zu ungenau neuen
forschungsergebnissen der university of
nottingham zufolge habe man sich bei
solchen schätzungen bisher auch mehr als
nur ein bisschen gehört denn wie
christopher konzil ice berichtet habe
man noch mehr als 90 prozent der
galaxien im universum zu erkunden im
zuge des raid observatoriums origins die
server kurz kurz errechneten sich die
forscher anhand von bestehenden galaxie
modellen unter zuhilfenahme des hubble
teleskops und weiterer teleskop
aufnahmen die bis heute noch im
verborgenen gebliebenen galaxien das
resultat unser universum umfasst rund
zwei billionen galaxien die natürlich
auch eine hohe anzahl an sternen
aufweisen die zahl der galaxien ist
damit zehnmal so hoch wie bisher
angenommen
was erwartet uns denn dann in der
zukunft wenn wir erst jetzt feststellen
dass wir eigentlich so wenig von unserem
universum kennen das fragt sich auch
konzils zitat wer weiß welche spannenden
eigenschaften wir finden werden wenn wir
diese galaxien mit zukünftigen
generationen von teleskopen erforschen
zitat ende es bleibt also weiter
spannend neue crew die internationale
raumstation iss bekommt neue
besatzungsmitglieder
der gerichtshof andrej borisenko und
shane kim bro traten am 19 oktober 2016
ihre voraussichtlich fünf monate langen
mission ins all an
es sieht so aus als wären die drei
menschen zusammen mit einem zugabteil
auf dem weg zum nächsten bahnhof
es geht aber tatsächlich zwei tage durch
das weltall
wurde ein hiv medikament gefunden zitat
diese ergebnisse machten uns sprachlos
sie waren einfach erstaunlich zitat ende
die worte von anthony fauci vom us
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases kurz in die in
bitterster klingen emotional berührt und
für rund 36 millionen menschen weltweit
hoffnungsvoll er spricht über die
resultate einer im fachmagazin science
veröffentlichten klinischen studie über
therapieansätze im fall von
immundefizienz wären zu denen auch der
hi virus gehört an rhesusaffen testeten
die forscher sogenannte alpha 4 beta 7
antikörper vor der einjährigen
verabreichung dieser antikörper und
gängiger an trug retro viralen
medikamenten infizierten sie die affen
mit einem immundefizienz virus
es war der simi ahnen immundefizienz
virus und tatsächlich ein jahr therapie
schien äußerst erfolgreich gewesen zu
sein zitat wir haben guten grund zur
hoffnung dass die therapie im menschen
ganz ähnlich funktioniert es ist bekannt
dass die s ii und die viren sich
insbesondere in den cd4 plus t zellen in
der darmschleimhaut vermehren und eine
chronische infektion etablieren der
antikörper verhindert das einwandern
dieser immunzellen in die
darmschleimhaut eine weitere ausbreitung
der viren wird dadurch effektiv
unterbunden so lutz walter vom deutschen
primatenzentrum warum der antikörper
eine solche effektive wirkung zeigte
können sich die forscher allerdings noch
nicht vollständig erklären wenn euch das
video gefallen hat lass mir gerne einen
daumen nach oben und ein kostenloses abo
da dafür hier klicken
und wenn ihr hier klickt komme zu einem
video nehmen wir uns mit der
überraschend schnellen ausdehnung
unseres universums beschäftigen und
empire schon erfahrung in krankenhäusern
mit keimen gemacht die diese neuen
erkenntnisse bestätigen könnten schreibt
mir eure erfahrung und meinung in die
kommentare und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran